WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US.
THANK YOU SEVEN, PRESIDENT
TRUMP, LINDSEY, THANK YOU,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY
JOINING US WITH MORE REACTION,
ERIC TRUMP IS WITH US.
ERIC, YOU WERE WITH YOUR DAD
THAT MORNING, THAT DAY, A WEEK
AGO.
LET'S GO THROUGH WHAT YOU KNOW
AND NOW THESE NEW DEVELOPMENTS.
BUT I ALSO WANT YOU TO STAND
BACK AND LOOK AT THE 6-YEAR
HISTORY THAT I JUST LAID OUT
HERE.
I MEAN, YOU HAVE, YOU HAVE A GUY
BY THE NAME OF PETER STRZOK
SAYING WE WILL STOP HIM.
THIS IS IN THE SUMMER OF 2016
LEADING INTO YOUR FATHER'S
ELECTION.
THEN IF YOUR PLAN DOESN'T WORK,
DON'T WORRY, WE HAVE AN
INSURANCE POLICY.
IT'S LIKE THE UNLIKELIHOOD THAT
YOU DIE -- IF YOU'RE 40, OR
BELOW 40.
HE ACTUALLY SAID THAT.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE THAT SIGNED
THESE FISA WARRANTS WERE EVER
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
HOW CAN WE SAY WE HAVE EQUAL
JUSTICE IN THIS COUNTRY, AND ALL
THOSE PEOPLE GOT AWAY WITH IT?
>> WELL, WE CAN'T SEAN BECAUSE
WE DON'T.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE ONE THING
I'LL TELL YOU, IT CAUSED THE
GREATEST FUNDRAISING, MY
FATHER'S POLL NUMBERS HAVE
ABSOLUTELY GONE THROUGH THE
ROOF.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
ANY OTHER REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE ALL KIND OF
DISAPPEARED.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN IN THE
EQUATION.
LAST NIGHT I HAD AN ARGUMENT
BETWEEN TWO PEOPLE IN A
RESTAURANT WHO WERE TRYING TO
BUY LAURA AND I DINNER TO
APOLOGIZE FOR WHAT THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT HAS DONE TO
OUR FAMILY, SEAN.
I MEAN, YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE THE
ENERGY OUT THERE.
I'VE BEEN THROUGH ALL OF THESE
FIRE STORMS OVER THE YEAR, I'VE
NEVER SEEN AMERICA MORE MAD THAN
IT IS RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S ONLY SO MANY TIMES YOU
CAN CRY WOLF.
PEOPLE ARE NOT BUYING THE SHAM
IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY SEE THE WEAPONIZATION OF
THE FBI.
THEY'RE CALLING IT THE POLICE
STATE IN THIS COUNTRY.
PEOPLE GET THIS FOR WHAT IT IS,
SEAN.
YOU KNOW, THEY'VE REMOVED THE
WOOL FROM PEOPLE'S EYES AND
PEOPLE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
ON.
THEY'RE TARGETING DONALD TRUMP,
THEY'RE TARGETING HIS FAMILY AND
EVERYBODY AROUND HIM.
THEY'RE TARGETING HIS LAWYERS.
ANYBODY THAT'S CLOSE TO DONALD
TRUMP, ANYBODY WHO'S EFFECTIVE
THEY'RE TARGETING RIGHT NOW AND
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THIS FOR
EXACTLY WHAT IT'S WORTH.
>> Sean: I NAMED ALL OF THE
NAMES, ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
SIGNED THE FISA WARRANT, I READ
THE TEXTS OF PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE.
I READ THE LIST OF EVERY
CONSERVATIVE ASSOCIATED WITH
YOUR DAD AND THE PREDAWN RAIDS,
GUNS DRAWN IN SOME CASES THE
MEDIA TIPPED OFF SO THEY CAN
CAPTURE IT ALL ON CAMERA AT 5:45
ON CAMERA, HOW CONVENIENT.
AND NOW YOUR OWN FATHER'S HOME
HAS BEEN RAIDED AND THEY JUST
STARTED TAKING BOXES OUT
RANDOMLY AND GOING THROUGH
MELANIA'S WARDROBE APPARENTLY AS
WELL.
AND THE QUESTION IS, BACK IN
JUNE, YOUR FATHER OFFERED TO
GIVE THEM EVERYTHING, ISN'T THAT
TRUE?
THE ROOM THAT THEY ASKED HIM TO
PAD LOCK, WHICH HE AGREED TO?
>> YEAH, THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT,
SEAN.
MY FATHER HAS BEEN SO
COOPERATIVE.
AND THAT'S WHAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO THE WHOLE FAMILY.
MY FATHER SAID ANYTHING YOU GUYS
NEED, LET US KNOW.
ANYTHING YOU NEED LET US KNOW.
THE LAWYER WHEN I FIRST TOLD HIM
ABOUT THIS, WAS LIKE I CAN'T
BELIEVE THIS, WE HAD THE
GREATEST RELATIONSHIP WITH THESE
PEOPLE.
YOUR FATHER WAS JUST IN JUNE.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY THEY PUT
THAT IN WRITING.
>> YOU LET US KNOW AND WE'LL
GIVE IT TO YOU.
>> Sean: THEY PUT THAT IN
WRITING IN FEBRUARY OF THIS
YEAR, SAYING YOU'VE BEEN SO
COOPERATIVE.
SO THIS REALLY ISN'T ABOUT --
ISN'T THIS REALLY ABOUT A
FISHING EXPEDITION, JANUARY 6TH,
TAXES, OR ANYTHING ELSE, YOU
KNOW, IF YOUR FATHER SPIT ON THE
SIDEWALK?
ISN'T THAT WHAT THEY'RE REALLY
LOOKING FOR?
>> ABSOLUTELY IT'S A FISHING
EXPEDITION.
I MEAN THEY PULLED THE WARRANT
ON FRIDAY, THEY DIDN'T ACTUALLY
SQUAT THE WARRANT UNTIL MONDAY.
SO WHEN I HEAR ABOUT NONSENSE
EXPIRATIONS ABOUT NUCLEAR CODES.
FBI AGENTS WERE SO BUSY OVER A
WEEKEND, OVER NUCLEAR CODES THEY
WAITED FOUR DAYS.
IT'S NONSENSE.
IT'S THE EXACT SAME PLAY BOOK
THEY USED IN RUSSIA, THE EXACT
SAME REPORTERS ARE BEING LEAKED
INFORMATION THAT WERE USED AS
THE SOURCES FOR THE WHOLE RUSSIA
HOAX.
GO LINE UP ALL THE REPORTERS WHO
WERE GETTING INSIDE INFORMATION,
UNSOLICITED INFORMATION DURING
THE RUSSIA HOAX, ARE THE EXACT
SAME PEOPLE THE FBI ARE LEAKING
TO NOW, THE SAME REPORTERS
REPORTING ON THE SAME THING, THE
SAME ASSOCIATION GOING TO THEIR
FRIENDS IN THE DEMOCRATIC MEDIA
WHO ARE EFFECTIVELY THE LOBBYIST
ARM OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
LEAKING STORIES ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP.
WE'RE 90 DAYS OUT SEAN FROM THE
MIDTERMS.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING, TIMING IS
NOT SURPRISING AND IT'S BACK
FIRING ON THESE PEOPLE.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
WILL YOU -- YOU STILL HAVE THE
SURVEILLANCE TAPE, IS THAT
CORRECT?
ARE YOU ALLOWED TO SHARE THAT
WITH THE COUNTRY?
>> ABSOLUTELY, SEAN, AT THE
RIGHT TIME.
AND YOUR BODYCAM POINT WAS SPOT
ON.
THAT'S WHY COPS WEAR BODYCAM.
THEY DON'T TELL YOU TO TURN OFF
CAMERAS, THEY WANT TRANSPARENCY
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
>> Sean: AND YOU KNOW FOR A FACT
THEY ASKED FOR THE CAMERAS TO BE
TURNED OFF.
>> THEY ASKED FOR THE CAMERAS TO
BE TURNED OFF.
>> Sean: WOW.